in some cases whether it's out of malice
or necessity tv writers decide the best
way to say goodbye to an actor is to
straight up annihilate the character
here are a few tv and film characters
who were killed off because of an
actor's awful behavior
between 1987 and 1989 the late j thomas
played a recurring role of hockey player
eddie labeck on the hit sitcom cheers
lebeck is a hockey player for the boston
bruins who gets involved with the tough
no-nonsense waitress carla
played by rhea pearlman and eventually
the pair tied the knot
sadly their wedded bliss doesn't last
long the bruins fire eddie because of
his age so he's forced to take a job as
a skating penguin in a traveling ice
show
in a season 8 episode we learned the
former hockey player was killed in a
bizarre zamboni accident
according to cheers writer ken levine
the hockey player's demise was the
result of the actor saying the wrong
thing
while the wrong person was listening in
a 2006 blog post
levine explained that at the same time
thomas had a recurring role on cheers he
was also a dj in los angeles
when a caller asked him on the air what
it was like working on cheers thomas
joked that it was quote brutal because
he had to kiss ria pearlman
according to levine pearlman happened to
be listening to the show
and as a result thomas was never seen on
cheers again
a few years before he was chopping
through orcs as gimli and peter
jackson's lord of the rings series john
reese davis played professor maximilian
arturo on the science fiction series
sliders
jesus marion joseph i think i've just
seen god and i could have sworn he was
driving a cadillac
arturo acts as mentor to quinn played by
jerry o'connell as they and their
friends use wormholes to travel to
parallel universes
in the season three two-parter exodus
arturo sacrifices himself to save quinn
taking a bullet meant for the younger
hero
nearly two decades after his departure
from sliders reese davis told digital
spy that the real reason he took the
bullet wasn't to save quinn
but to save himself from bad writing he
says the writers on sliders didn't have
the vision to realize the full potential
of the series
he also called the scripts quote
incomprehensible gibberish
reese davis went on to say that he
clashed with the writers on a regular
basis
the actor recalled in an interview i
would go to the writers and complain but
they say john why don't you just say the
words as written i say i tell you what
i will actually say the words as written
when you can actually write intelligent
sentences
rhys davis wasn't clear about whether he
was fired or quit but either way he says
his conflicts with writers were to blame
for his departure beginning in 1988
roseanne aired for nine seasons ending
in 1997
then in 2018 roseanne enjoyed what was
initially an extremely successful
revival with the original cast on board
and hit ratings the new roseanne looks
set to possibly enjoy
many more seasons i have an announcement
i'm having a baby a baby what
then in july 2018 roseanne barr tweeted
a racist insult about valerie jarrett a
former advisor to president barack obama
soon after abc fired barr and canceled
the series
but while it was the end for roseanne it
wasn't the end of the character's story
in october 2018 the counters premiered
featuring all of roseanne's cast
minus barr the first episode reveals
that the conor family matriarch has died
at first a heart attack was blamed for
her death but later in the premiere we
learned she died from an opioid overdose
rosanna the connor's showrunner bruce
helford said the choice to kill her
character was made to make her departure
permanent
alfred also went on to say that the
manner of her death was meant to be one
that was relevant and could inspire
discussion for the greater good about
the american working class
barr apparently didn't agree after the
premiere she wrote a long response to
her character's demise on the connors
saying the choice was too grim in morbid
for a family-oriented show
in the matrix films one of the most
conspicuous absences after the first
movie is tank
played by marcus chong in spite of being
one of the few good guys to survive the
original film
his character was killed off between
movies and doesn't appear in either the
matrix reloaded or the matrix
revolutions
the reason tank dies is that when he was
approached to reprise the role
chong decided on an absolutely bizarre
negotiating strategy
the writer director team of the
wachowskis reportedly wanted chong to
return and offered him 250 000
to do so but depending on which version
of chong you ask
that was either way too much or not
nearly enough
chung wanted 1 million to reprise the
role of tank but the wachowskis refused
so chong had his lawyer deliver a letter
in which the actor said that he would
return
for the sequels either for 500 000 or
for free
chong wrote i will do it for free
because i love the project and i want to
protect the role and the integrity of
the wachowski's vision
instead the wachowskis decided the
franchise could survive without tank
unfortunately for everyone involved it
wasn't the last the wachowskis heard
from chong
he was arrested for threatening the
filmmakers and he later unsuccessfully
sued warner brothers
aol time warner and the wachowski's
production company for breach of
contract slander and fraud
for eight seasons charlie sheen played
jingle writer charlie harper on the cbs
sitcom
two and a half men but in the season
nine premiere it's revealed that harper
dies an utterly ridiculous death when a
helicopter drops a grand piano on top of
him
sheen's character is then replaced by
internet tycoon walden schmidt
played by ashton kutcher while the
manner of harper's death likely
surprised plenty of viewers
the fact that he died surprised no one
long before he was even cast on two and
a half men
sheen had built himself a disturbing
reputation that included drug abuse and
domestic violence
in february 2011 sheen hammered the
final nails in the character's coffin
with vicious attacks on the two and a
half men creator chuck lorre
when sheen appeared on the alex jones
show and hurled anti-semitic insults
directed at lori and posted an open
letter rant on tmz
in early march warner brothers announced
enough was enough
and sheen was fired from two and a half
men however the season nine premiere
proved not to be quite the end of
charlie harper
in the two-part series finale it's
revealed charlie stalker neighbor rose
faked his death and has been keeping him
as a prisoner in the pit for the last
four years
harper escapes but he's once again
killed by a helicopter that drops a
grand piano on him
for nine seasons the late soul singer
and actor isaac hayes lent his voice to
the character chef on comedy central's
controversial animated show south park
chef would often deliver wisdom to the
show's heroes
wisdom that usually involve breaking
into a soul song
but in 2006 hayes asked to be released
from his contract
hayes cited what he called the show's
quote intolerance and bigotry towards
religious beliefs as his reason for
departing
hayes a scientologist didn't directly
reference the season 9 episode trapped
in the closet
which criticized scientology but many
including south park creators trey
parker and matt stone
assumed that episode is what he was
talking about in an official statement
from comedy central stone pointed out
what he saw as hazes hypocrisy
writing isaac never had a problem with
the show making fun of christians
muslims mormons or jews
he got a sudden case of religious
sensitivity when it was his religion
featured on the show
however we should point out that hades's
son has said that his dad
had a stroke in 2006 and that the church
of scientology pinned this letter in his
name
so perhaps the actor wasn't responsible
for the letter
regardless in the season 10 premiere
parker and stone made sure that hayes
knew how they felt about his departure
after his hiatus chef returns to south
park as a member of the super adventure
club a blatant stand-in for scientology
at the end of the episode chef is on a
rope bridge as it's struck by lightning
the bridge breaks he catches on fire
falls down a cliffside
and winds up impaled on a branch then
he's shot and mauled by both a mountain
lion and
a bear of the things actress shannon
doherty is known for
working and playing well with others
isn't one of them she was reportedly the
source of plenty of behind the scenes
chaos
on the set of the teen drama beverly
hills 90210
including a fistfight with co-star jenny
garth
in 2015 doherty's 90210 co-star tori
spelling admitted that she asked her
father
90210 producer aaron spelling to fire
doherty a request he honored
regardless aaron spelling tapped
dougherty again for charmed a
supernatural drama about witch sisters
who used their powers to fight evil
doherty played the oldest of the three
sisters prue and was joined by alyssa
milano as phoebe and holly marie combs
as piper
but while the series lasted eight
seasons and won an impressive cult
following
doherty was only there for the first
three in the season three finale prue
was murdered by a demon assassin shacks
played by michael bailey smith this time
while doherty's departure was because of
all the wrong kinds of drama
she refused to get the proverbial acts
for unspecified reasons dardy and
co-star milano had stopped speaking to
one another during the course of the
series
when milano demanded dardy be fired the
latter reportedly heard about it through
the grapevine
rather than be fired doherty not only
quit she directed all hell breaks loose
the season three finale in which prue
meets her
end by the end of the sitcom community
almost half of the actors in the
original lineup of greendale community
college's most well-known study group
had moved on
but one of the only characters who
literally didn't survive the series was
chevy chase's piers hawthorne
while piers had a penchant for faking
heart attacks throughout the show in
order to get out of trouble apparently
his final one was the real deal
according to community creator dan
harmon the main reason for hawthorne's
death was that chase
and his character were a little bit too
much alike
good evening i'm god and here's the news
the last straw fell during the filming
of the season 4 episode
advanced documentary filmmaking during
filming chase apparently went on an
angry rant which included a racial slur
afterwards nbc and chase came to the
agreement season 4 would be chase's last
though he made a cameo in the season 5
premiere as a hologram his death was
announced later that season
harmon has since gone on record that the
rant during season 4 was just the tip of
the iceberg
not only did chase have a history of
leaving the set before filming was
completed but in a 2018 new yorker
interview
chase's co-star donald glover said that
the older actor would often make racist
cracks and glover between takes
including suggesting that the audience
only found glover funny because he was
black
in the first two seasons of cbs's police
procedural criminal minds
mandy patinkin played expert criminal
profiler jason gideon
early in season three potenkin left the
show abruptly and joe montene stepped in
as the new profiler david rossi
so why the change up potenkin had asked
to be released from his contract
after failing to show up at a table read
then further down the road in the show's
10th season
it was revealed that gideon had been
murdered off-screen by a suspect from
one of his earliest cases
in a 2012 interview with the new york
magazine potenkin opened up about his
departure from criminal minds
saying that working on the show was one
of the biggest mistakes he'd ever made
apparently playing a criminal profiler
was having too many damaging side
effects on potential's mental and
spiritual well-being
potential went on to say it was very
destructive to my soul
and my personality he also suggested
that criminal minds and shows like it
were detrimental to society
potenkin warned audiences all over the
world use this programming as their
bedtime story
this isn't what you need to be dreaming
about
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one